good afternoon
colleagues good morning good evening to
all of you wherever you
are um I would like to welcome you to
this
webinar on resilient drylands innovating
for sustainable agricultural landscape
and
livelihoods my name is y yasmi and I'm a
special coordinator
for the plan production and protection
division at
FAO it is really a great honor to see
many of you joining this webinar and I'm
pretty sure some will still join later
on um so it's encouraging to see you
know how uh the subject matters is
relevant for for all of us colleagues I
invite you also to introduce yourself in
chat room maybe where you are from so
that we know you know uh in term of
where you know where you are and and so
for so feel free to to write your name
and you know your country where you are
based so the drylands you know are very
important topics for FAO and for all of
us not only because of the significant
contribution to
agriculture but also for pecularities of
the of the drylands and a lot in know
pecularity of challenges that they are
facing so today we are so pleased to
have an opportunity to discuss this to
share lesson learned to share best
practices and also you know we look
forward to get your feedback and views
on how we can actually work on Dryland
better in the future to address the
issues of poverty food insecurity and
malnutrition
colleagues uh participants uh and and
Este team uh panels without further Ado
uh I would like to start this webinar by
inviting uh Miss Beth Beall FAO deputy
director General to give her welcoming
remark Beth offer to
you thanks very much Yi and to all of
our distinguished guests uh to all of
our colleagues Coles uh and um everyone
who is with us here today uh obviously
we are pulling from a very Global
audience so I need to say good morning
good afternoon and good evening uh to
each of you depending upon your
geographic location I do very much
appreciate everyone's taking the time to
join us today for I think this important
discussion Yi has already indicated that
uh drylands certainly have their own
unique uh
characteristics um and they are critical
to achieving Global Food security and so
drawing attention uh through today's
webinar on how we innovate for
sustainable agricultural Landscapes and
liih hoods I think is an incredibly
timely discussion I'm also really
pleased to see some familiar and
friendly faces here on the screen uh
Jackie Hughes uh here uh with us again
uh as our partner
uh errat uh and FAO have worked on many
things together over the years and with
her role as director General we have
very recently uh been able to take on a
number of these important types of
topics together but we are also joined
by a number of other distinguished
speakers uh from across many continents
uh I'm looking forward to hearing from
them uh hopefully meeting them in the
future as well because I know they will
enrich today's discussions uh each
bringing their own perspectives and
their unique knowledge I have I think
many ways the easy job uh of setting the
stage a little bit and then I get to
listen uh it's not often that I get to
sort of sit in the background and really
soak in the information and the
knowledge from so many of our partners
but let me try uh to do just a little
bit of of staging for today's uh webinar
discussion we I think all appreciate
that dry lands uh make up over 40% of
the earth's land surface they are home
to two billion people on the planet and
also Supply about 60% of the world's
food production making them a very
unique type of ecosystem but one that is
also characterized quite harshly by
water scarcity and low precipitation but
although these regions are dry they are
not barren they are productive
landscapes for plants and animals but
they certain they certainly require our
committed attention between climate
variability unsustainable land use
conflicts and demographic shifts we are
seeing the continued degradation of
these ecosystems and these are areas
that are facing unprecedented challenges
but at the same time hold enormous
potential they are sources for abundant
soil energy they do have a rich
biodiversity within them and there are
countless opportunities to enhance the
productivity and the resilience of
production systems focused on dry lands
and I think this where today's
discussion comes fully into play is
where innovation has an opportunity to
play a key role to tap into these
opportunities and Innovation can be the
accelerator for the needed change to
scale up best practices um and
ultimately to reach more of an impact
but an impact at scale FAO has a long
history of supporting sustainable
Dryland agriculture around the world we
have contributed to the great green wall
initiative in Africa to restore the
continent's degraded Landscapes we have
supported farmer field schools in Asia
to the drylands of meso America to
restore degraded drylands working to
increase crop productivity and
ultimately enhance community and
Landscape resilience across these
continents and we also have initiatives
such as the grazing with trees
initiative it integrates forestry and
agricultural practices to restore dry
lands while increasing local resilience
against disasters and climate hazards
and alongside uh unep we are leading the
UN decade of ecosystem restoration an
important opportunity to draw all of our
attention to protecting and Reviving
ecosystems all around the world and I
think it too being featured as a decade
gives us an opportunity to build a
stronger more broad-based Global
movement in support of dry lands and
other important ecosystems but we still
have more to do and I think that's where
a conversation and a discussion like the
one we're having today is so important
for our part uh here at FAO in just a
few days in fact starting next Monday we
will be meeting and convening in FAO
headquarters the 29th session of the FAO
committee on agriculture or for those of
you well familiar with fao's
nomenclature and acronyms we call it
coag uh coag is one of four technical
committees uh governing body process of
FAO that provides guidance on
agriculture related policies we view
Global issues and Trends and we advise
on emerging topics and I believe this
will also be an opportunity to continue
building on this discussion because in
fact it was back in
2020 uh at the 27th session of coag
where there was an endorsement by
members of fao's global program on
sustainable Dryland
agriculture demonstrating that dry lands
are indeed a priority so so I hope that
with today's discussion and with the
bringing together of many of our
partners bringing together our members
around these types of unique topics that
we can find ways to best use innovation
Technologies data and other sustainable
practices to really Elevate and make the
drylands ecosystems of the planet far
more resilient than they are today so
yuy with that I think I'll stop um I'll
turn it back over to you and look
forward very much to hearing from so
many of our uh Partners who are here
with us for the panel and for the
discussion and um also hopefully some
very rich feedback and engagement from
those of us who are joining us online
thanks
again thank you very much Beth for your
encouraging welcome remarks and also for
outlining the importance of the you know
of drylands some of our featured work on
drylands and also you stress the
importance of you know working together
and bringing the subject back to the
table because of the important roles uh
for farmers and for the livelihood and
also for food security so thank you so
much Beth uh dear participants I see
that we have hit uh 200 participants I
still invite you to introduce yourself
where you are from I can see that you
know some say good evening from the
Philippines from Indonesia India Yemen
so many tury so please you know feel
free to introduce yourself in the chat
colleagues um we will set up the stage
for this discussion uh by a message from
a director of land and water division of
FAO Mr Lee Fang Lee who is unfortunately
du due to other commitment cannot be
with us uh but he has recorded his
messages for us so heo could you kindly
play the message from director Lee thank
you dear deputy director General um
backto distinguished guests dear
colleagues ladies and gentlemen I'm very
pleased to share a few Point
contributing contributing to the
discussion on resilient dry land at this
seminar you may recall that I report the
status of land and water resources for
food and agriculture 2021 concluded that
pressures on land and water resources
are pushing the ecosystems to their
productive limit compromising
agriculture production and intensifying
poverty and Mal nutrition in all regions
especially in the fragile Dryland areas
over 95% of food is produced on land and
begins with soils and water we need to
work together to produce more with less
and safe guard these resources for the
future desertification land degradation
and short have increasing impacts on
food security and the livelihoods of
mils negatively affect food production
water and soil resources and increasing
carbon emission and vulnerability to
climate change estimates indicate that
humid induced land degradation affect at
least 1.6 billion hectares worldwide
impacting directly on 3.2 billion people
more than 60% of the human induced land
degradation
is indeed taking place on agriculture
lands put the Agri Food Systems under
unprecedented pressure D is one of the
most destructive natural disasters
severe
Dr inance and becoming more frequent and
affecting food security especially in
the dry areas and in countries with
reduced capacity to absorb the shocks by
2050 draws may affect an estimated 34 of
the world population it is a global
issue together we need to urgently shift
the draw management Paradigm Paradigm
from reactive to proactive approaches to
increase dra risk preparedness
strengthen adaptation capacity and move
away from emergency
actions the frequency and intensity of
sand and dark systems especially in arid
and semiarid regions have increased over
recent decades due to the land use land
cover changes and climate factors with
many regions projected to experience
increasing arid aridity and D frequency
in due to climate
change sand and dark storms have major
transboundary impact on environment CL
climate Health livelihood Agriculture
and food security and the social
economic well-being of the site healthy
soils are essential for sustainable and
resilient AGR Food Systems as they
provide safe and nutritious food
regulate both water and carbon cycles
and support
over and support about 60% of
biodiversity on this
planet long and short-term development
and investment decisions addressing the
restoration of degradated lands require
integrated strategy
that must consider soil organic carbon
stocks soil Rec carbonization strategies
can be a game changer towards towards
achieving land degradation neutrality
objectives land Tous security is
necessary to encourage people to invest
sustainably in their land to fight
desertification land degradation and
drought and it's crucial to achieve land
degradation neutrality supporting
countries in dry areas to increase their
resilience of livelihood and to reduce
the impacts on vulnerable communities is
at the heart of fa's mandate sustainable
land water use and management is key to
maintain and sustain food production and
has to be at the heart of any Agri food
system
transformation integrated land use
planning responsible land governance and
land Tous security and Dr resilience are
of fundamental importance for achieving
food security SEC especially on the dry
in the dry
areas the restoration of degradated
agriculture land needs urgent urgent
political leadership massive investment
and concerted actions on the ground I
feel will continue work with the
countries and partners to combat
desertification and drought to achieve
food security and nutrition with that I
thank you very much for your attention
and I wish you a very prod Ive
discussion thank you very much Le Fang
for setting the stage and context of our
discussion today I will move on uh to
the next
speaker uh Miss Jackie Hughes the
director general of rrad Jackie will
share research and development
perspective with the title critical
development and opportunity for Dryland
agriculture jaie over to you
thank you very much Yodi and good
evening good afternoon and good morning
ddg Beth and the many colleagues and
friends who have joined us on this
webinar I'm going to be talking about
where the dry lands are the main issues
the latest developments and
opportunities for the future which is
absolutely
critical next the
drylands yes thank you the drylands as
Beth said cover 40% of the Earth's
surface land
surface but the frightening fact is that
it's 66% of Africa 40% of Asia and 24%
of Europe are covered with dry lands
whether they are arid or semi arid
next although it is extremely dry and
it's very difficult to get sufficient
water you will see the agricultural
success
happens we have rainfed we have
Highlands lowlands irrigated but
agricultural success is predicated
around the successful management of
water resources to achieve sustainable
livestock crop livestock or crop crop
system
next they looking at all these issues um
productivity we have heat and drought we
have soil degradation we need inputs we
need fod and feed there are pests and
diseases we need
pollinators and an exceptional drought
can cause huge yield losses I mean a
truly exceptional drought 100% loss but
an exceptional drought will give you
about 70% loss of soybean maze wheat
rice and as we heard just now the dry
lands are
degraded and over a billion people in
more than a 100 countries are at risk
climate change and climatic events we're
all seeing them and we've got increased
warming we also have cooling the
rainfall climatic events changes in
atmospheric
CO2 and climate change is expected to
cause
approximately
250,000 additional deaths per year from
2030 to
2050 we must either mitigate or
adapt looking at markets Market linkages
in some of our arried areas are poor we
have asymmetrical access to information
we need digital tools
globalization
transportation in Colombia SMS weather
Information Services reduce crop losses
by 11 to
14% every incremental increase in
production and harvest is
important we have Labor and civil
unrest we've got aging farming
communities agriculture isn't a
preferred occupation anymore prohibitive
labor cost gender related labor issues
civil
unrest and in my point of view the first
real climate change conflict took place
in the Sahel in 2003 when the war in
darur exposed how the convergence of
environmental and political factors can
lead to
conflict policies got to be adapted to
local needs and when adopted they need
to facilitate resilience and
productivity must be fit for purpose and
you've got to manage
tradeoffs capacity development has to be
properly determined correctly
implemented and you have to address the
needs of the different segments of
communities the farmers the production
systems because communities with lower
levels of adaptive capacity experience
higher climate imp climate impacts due
to their reduced ability to cope with
climate
change
next there have been developments it's
not all a bad set of stories here but
the landscape approach we need to be
holistic looking at watersheds
perhaps we've got to have drought heat
tolerant varieties that will survive and
yield we've had a greater Focus on the
dry lands think thanks to the
international year of millets and then
the G20 in
India but we have to continue that was
just the
beginning we need the crops to be
nutritious biofortified crops
exist sometimes there's enough food but
it's not good
nutrition we're harvesting water is the
dry lands and More than 70% of the area
of the Indian semary Tropics has high to
medium potential for implementing
rainwater harvesting but we don't always
do
it for our soil we've been putting in a
lot of inputs but not in the dry lands
and one siiz solution such as
regenerative agriculture it doesn't fit
all glass houses and hydroponics are a
possibility for the high value crops
which can be grown in dry lands um you
see them growing in the deserts of Saudi
Arabia so on protected cultivation but
high value crops
next We Now understand better physiology
and productivity we know about root
architecture for example and canopy
structure we know that if we get
increased light penetration to lower
canopy we can increase yields by up to
177% in some
crops we've got to minimize risk to
Farmers by
diversifying we need to use digital
tag but the information has to be not
only available it has to be
transparent and when we use machine
learning we have to make sure that what
is produced by us is correct usable fit
for
purpose we need to facilitate
breeding whether it's um through
genomics or other molecular tools we
know how to do it but the policies and
the regulatory EnV environment is not
always supportive speed breeding Works
conventional breeding six Generations a
year for some crops now so that helps
and we know we need
Partnerships but we need better
Partnerships stronger sustainable
Partnerships
next because I put it to you even
however hard we try are we going to be
able to meet the goals that we have set
ourselves and the figures that we're
seeing it's not looking good
particularly for the dry lands
next there are opportunities though this
is the great part
um one of the things we need though is
increased funding that is critical for
research agriculture doesn't get enough
funding to start with compared to
example medicine but we need more for
the dry lands I'll come on to the health
and nutrition aspect but for soils we'll
hear more about
soils but Farmers always overestimate
the sizes of their Farms they've been
putting too much on their Farms when
they could afford or even find the input
let's make sure that we target the
recommendations very
carefully
um the diagnostic tools that we have for
targeted advisories
we we can do things like
traceability um using machine learning
we can add valued
products uh capacity development it
needs to be done not nationally but
globally Continental Regional because if
you're limited by a country or a
specific group of people the
interactions aren't there and you don't
get the full benefit of the capacity
development if we look at digital egg
there are so many
opportunities whether you're using
satellites drones or any other type of
Technology but it's got to be available
to everyone and the information has to
be
true
next I was talking about the holistic
approach to health nutrient-rich
food we're looking at soil microbi
biomes we're looking at plant
microbiomes gut microbiomes the
interactions and synergies using big
data we can use Ai and we need to
understand the relationships between
them that lead to Good Health when we
have bio fortified crops which I was
talking about earlier make sure that the
nutrients are
bioavailable they are not always we need
to know how to prepare the food um make
sure that even when we breed the plants
it will be a bio available
nutrient we need dietary diversity it's
a very simple thing have diversity on
your plate we've been talking about it
for years it's not happening how do we
do it and however much we do for one
Health we need also to minimize chronic
infections that prevent uptake of
nutrients we don't do it all together we
do it bit by bit we need to pull it all
together
if we could go on to the next slide
please I'm talking about Gene editing on
this this slide it's becoming more
popular in some countries for example
India there's a simple regulatory
environment for Gene edited crops not
transgenic crops and for intractable
problems Gene editing can solve
rancidity in PE millet flour might solve
a
toxins and if countries still cannot
accept Gene edited plants because
somebody might think it's scary at least
then we will know exactly what we're
looking for in gene banks in the
diversity of our crops to use
conventional breeding so don't write off
Gene
editing if you think the regulatory
environment won't permit it it's an
amazing tool and we need to use it
quickly next other opportunities
include crop management big advances in
productivity are needed and we need to
get our options right we need to have
the management options absolutely spot
on I'll talk about
adaptation PES and diseases are really
um taking off with climate
change we can use remote sensing apps to
identify and TR track and control but it
needs to be done on a holistic level
just controlling one field is not good
enough you've got to control a landscape
to stop the spread of pests and
diseases we can
help uh increase availability of
nitrogen in the soil using biological
nitrification inhibition again
technology driven but it would
help we can and um Advocate the use of
new technologies Gene editing for
example but scientists are not the ones
to do that advocacy very well we don't
do it well we need others to help
support us and some of these crops used
for the dry lands have industrial
uses yes we want food we want nutrition
but money is also important so let's not
forget that and I believe we should
foster entrepreneurship opportun unities
that's a way of getting the youth back
in um and we can scale and deliver
impact which is what we're all
about next I mentioned crop adaptation
and selection I put it to you all that
we can no longer breed crops for today
we have to breed crops for maybe 10 to
15 years
ahead why are we forcing crops which
love a semi- temperate climate why are
we trying to breed them forcefully to
the
drylands the drylands are expanding as
the we reach the edges why not put in
crops that are adapted why give
ourselves such a huge headache trying to
adapt crops that don't like those
environments our crops need to be
tolerant of climatic events abiotic
stresses and broad-based resistance to
PES and diseases but we have to get it
all together one plant not a separate
trait
next and please can we work at a
landscape
approach we need Watershed level
approaches we need to manage water water
is owned it's used for irrigation
Fisheries for drinking and it's a cause
of
conflict we need to have the cereals the
legumes the horiculture the trees
diversify the cropping system we have
the tools we need data is plentiful it's
available and there are many
opportunities we need effective policies
to though to be able to implement them
I've given you a whole mish mash of all
the things that are wrong and all the
ways that we could work together but we
have to work at
scale individual Farms won't fix the
problem it has to be on across scale so
I hope it's given you a taste and I'm
looking forward to hearing if anybody
has the solutions that we can take
further thank you very much
everyone jaie thank you very much for
this succinct but comprehensive
presentation from you a very well
received and I think very critical many
of what you said are very relevant if
not all uh and thanks you know Jackie
for really bring this important issues
new developments opportunities yes we
have challenges but as you said we need
to work at scale and at landscape level
thank you Jackie uh colleagues for those
of who you who have just joined you can
start now asking question in the Q&A
chat um we will continue to the next
presenters our own uh makiko taguchi
will be sharing uh our work on Dryland
from fa perspective makiko off to
[Music]
you thank you very much Yi hello
everyone my name is makiko taguchi I'm
an agricultural officer with the plant
production and protection Division I
hope you're seeing my slide
okay perfectly yes great so I have the
honor to to share briefly about what our
division plant production protection
division is doing in the drylands
alongside other partners
okay so the first um program that I want
to mention is the Dryland sustainable
Landscapes uh initiative uh IMPACT
Program which uh I think flows nicely
after what Jackie just mentioned that we
really need to work at the landscape
level so this IMPACT program is funded
by the Global Environmental facility and
led by FAO and has started in 2021 and
until
2026 let's see so the program is working
uh in various forms supporting 11
countries in Africa and Central Asia one
of the ways is through this sustainable
landscape production
framework which addresses common
management challenges and drylands
through an integrated multi sectoral
approach and then breaking silos for
greater impact by shifting from
fragmented interventions to a cohesive
model through farmer field schools and a
improving access to seeds through
community seed banks and um business
incubation through forest and farm
facility the other element is the
integrated landscape assessment
methodology as Jackie just mentioned
data is available so through this uh
methodology we bring together data from
geospatial information systems such as
Google
Earth and down to household level data
so that uh tailored uh evidence-based
interventions can be made and these are
are shared and Lessons Learned are are
shared through a regional um exchange
mechanisms and also uh through these
community of practices that are set up
who are dealing with the data but also
with the production framework and this
is all supported not only by our
division but of course with the Land and
Water Division that Mr Lee shared and
also uh the forestry
division going a little bit deeper into
the community seed bank element that our
seeds and genetic resources team is
supporting this element is supporting
six countries from the sadak
region in focusing on the miombo and the
mopan Woodlands area in subsaharan
Africa so this uh community seed banks
are set up to help mitigate the negative
effects of land degradation and to help
a regional approach through the regional
uh exchange mechanism like I
mentioned and
then creating a s a sustainable and
scalable action through the coordination
with the sadak plant genetic resources
Center and it is also supported by uh
International platforms such as the
inter in international Treaty of plant
genetic resources which is also hosted
by FAO and this work is really focusing
on diversification that Jackie had just
mentioned it's all it's about
availability of quality seed through the
Community Banks uh seed banks making uh
available the well adapted crops and
varieties that some of them might be
traditional but because of of lack of of
Investments they may have kind of
disappeared from the
cultures helping uh Farmers to diversify
cropping systems and overall to improve
productivity and to have a diverse and
balanced diet and help helping Farmers
participate in new value
chains so in in that Community Seedbank
initiative also supported the
International year of millets that we
celebrated last year that Jackie also
mentioned uh millets is a one of the or
group of crops that are are suited for
Dryland environments so throughout the
year we have celebrated not only just
these 15 types of millets uh but um
various millets even Beyond these to
really focus on the the the traditions
and the cultures and the Cuisines that
have supported communities all around
the
world and I am happy to inform you that
the final report has just been published
today so you can visit the final report
of the international year of millets in
the link that is provided in the chat
and in the slide that you
see I would also like to bring attention
to an FAO Carta International technical
cooporation Network on Cactus that I've
been working on for the last decade this
community is working on on really
bringing together research and
development in Cactus it's a crop Duna
species is the main species but not only
that this group focuses on originates in
Mexico but now it's grown in in all over
the world in the Dryland areas we
currently have n over 900 members in 79
countries and the the really uh
interesting thing about this crop is
that it's or groups of crops is that
they're very resilient of course they're
Cactus they they Thrive well in Dryland
areas and they are versatile they are
good for human consumption as the fruits
or the pads of salads or vegetables and
as for fod it's it's an increasing crop
that is um recognized as a good source
of fod and it is also a good source of
bioenergy is G gaining a lot of interest
around around the world and next year
we'll be working with our partners zarta
and others to support the international
Congress on cacti as food fod and other
uses in uh Spain so please uh let me
know if you are interested in this work
as
well and on top of this I would also
like to mention that we have been
working in support of the US state
department and the African Union on the
vision for adaptive crops and soils are
or know known as V for some of you and
this is an an initiative that brings
attention to indigenous and traditional
crops that we some of them we have just
mentioned Jackie and I that are more
adapted uh to the local environmental
conditions and nutritious that can be
more nutritious than other major staple
crops that are grown in in the countries
and they have they are tend to be more
climate uh resilient and also um better
adapt to land
degradation so as Jackie just mentioned
it is important that these uh um
neglected and underutilized species um
get the attention they need for research
and development as well as policy and
investment
attention thank you very much for your
attention thank you very much makiko uh
I can see the a lot of convergence
between what you presented and that of
Jackies it's good you know to see how
you know um uh we are working you know
at Country level at landscape level to
promote uh to promote the dry lands um
so for sure you know uh as jaie said and
also B said you know we need to be
working together on this you know I
already see you know from these two
presentation how important it it is for
us to compare notes and to move together
uh to support Dryland
agriculture uh thank you again makiko
now I would like to move on to our next
presenters who will present managing
soil health and plan nutrition in
Dryland ecosystem in subsaharan Africa
it is my honor to invite uh Sami zingore
the director of research at African PL
nutrition Institute Sami over to you
Samy are you with
us yes thank you very much uh can you
see my presentation yes we can see it
but maybe you need to put it in
presentation mode now it's good it's
okay now go ahead oh excellent uh thank
you very much um for the introduction
and um greetings to colleagues and
partners joining us uh from um different
parts of uh the world it's a great
pleasure for me to be be part of this uh
very important and um timely discussion
on sustainable management of U uh
livelihoods and landscapes in the
drylands and I'm going to focus uh my
presentation today on issues related to
the intricate connection between soil
health and pl nutrition with the primary
focus in uh subsaharan
Africa uh I wanted to start by
illustrating the core um intricate uh
relationship between nutrient management
and some of the environmental and um
social and economic uh sustainability
challenges that uh we encounter in the
region at the Apex of uh the challenges
for agricultural sustainability in uh
Subs Africa is the law and inappropriate
nutrient application um southern Africa
currently has the lowest use of both
organic and um mineral fertilizers
resulting in um a soil Health crisis
that is associated with nutrient mining
with currently more than 30 cages of
nutrients being lost from agricultural
lands on the continent and there's also
the um parallel um challenges associated
with overgrazing that also deplete uh
the overall and nutrients in the system
over the long term this Cascades
into um land degradation uh which at
this point 65% of the crop land in the
African vland is actually uh considered
to be degraded uh resulting in major um
you know challenges and high risk for
non-responsive source that don't respond
to management and um this then is
associated with a whole host of other
environmental uh challenges including
um High emissions of carbon from and and
biodiversity losses mostly through area
expansion uh especially into vulnerable
drylands uh that then trigger a lot of
uh climate um you know change and
exacerbate the effect of climate change
as well and this then is uh expressed in
the major food uh and nutritional and
livelihood challenges that we find on
the continent so what I'm going to to
address today is to highlight the
importance then of building soil health
and systems resilience with a key focus
on addressing the core issue of plant
nutrition and um focusing on integrated
so fertility crop and water management
and then ensuring that this is done to
address climate change and then
also address uh the cor specific
Technologies due to the diversity of the
um system that we are working in in um
the um different parts of the continent
but we also need to pay attention to the
economic viability of uh the solutions
because in large Parts uh a lot of
technologies that work uh um you know
from a technical perspective are not
always providing the right solutions
that uh meet the socioeconomic uh
requirements of small holder
Farmers I wanted to
um provide an illustration here of um
studies that we've carried out in the
drylands in eastn southern Africa
looking at the impact of low input
systems on so carbon and so carbon is
used as a good indicator of so Health
due to its multiple functions uh for um
biological physical and uh chemical so
properties in a large part of the
systems under small holder low input
system so organic met decline finds very
rapidly in the initial years of
cultivation reaching um in about 10
years to less than 50% of the initial
sologic carbon uh stored in uh Native
um Woodlands or
grasslands and what is very striking is
that uh a large part of the carbon
losses which is also associated with
land degradation occur in the initial
years of cultivation and resulting in
very low crop productivity with yields
only in the range of 1 to 2 tons per
hect and land degradation results in
cells that respond very poorly to
management and this is a key challenge
was in large parts of the world soil
health issues are related to
intensification and overuse of uh um
pesticides and and and fertilizers it's
a compressing situation large parts of
the sou Africa where large part of the
land degradation is driven by low use of
nutrient inputs but what we also found
interesting is uh by investing in um n
Plant Nutrition uh by uh investing in
Balance fertilization with uh managing
prop procedures to improve sologic
carbon um in commercial farming systems
uh we observe that we could actually
double the Sol organic carbon in the
long term term and maintain much higher
yields highlighting the core value of
Plant Nutrition in improving so health
and also contributing to sustainable
Crop Production as
well then I just wanted to then
illustrate um some of the um processes
of land degradation and how they relate
to crop response and plant
nutrition um the degradation rest and
restoration trajectories associated with
crop productivity happen in a sequential
process uh in large parts of the systems
uh early part of the degradation is
associated with nutrient losses and
under such conditions in the a Zone we
can actually improve crop productivity
by focusing on PL nutrition as a key
component of increasing cor productivity
and by investing in Plant Nutrition we
also produce the biomass that is needed
to maintain I organic matter and soil
Health but as de addition advances and
you you have a chemical and biological
degradation taking place then the um
responsiveness of the cells are
diminished and the rate of restoration
is also diminished and in those systems
a greater focus on Integrated Solutions
becomes pertinent but under Advanced uh
degradation conditions a way I want to
highlight in the zone C uh this is where
degradation is very severe and nutrition
itself does not Sol solve the challenge
because SS become low responsive to
nutrient applications and under those
conditions Soul Health Restoration
becomes in the key entry point and this
is where a large part of the efforts in
regenerative agriculture and some of the
nature based solutions that are needed
first to rebuild soil Health before the
source can respond to nutrient
applications becomes the key entry point
for reversing
productivity then I just wanted to uh
End by highlighting that we have been
working in these conceptual Frameworks
uh addressing the critical need of Plant
Nutrition both in terms of mineral
fertilizers and Organics to support the
Continental Agricultural Development
agenda and we are proud as a pni to have
contributed in a leading role in the
development of Africa Union um fertiliz
and soul Health action plan which was
endorsed by the African government at
The Summit in Nairobi this year this
creates uh the priorities and set the
priorities of the continent for
sustainable soil Health uh and uh plan
nutrition and crop productivity for the
next decade it's a 10-year action plan
and the action plan focuses on
harnessing multi-stake order
Partnerships and Investments for
sustainable fertilizer and soul Health
Management and four key intervention
areas are covered in that action plan
which um will direct uh Innovation and
Investments uh through multiple
Partnerships in addressing the
challenges of so Health in the continent
a large part of what I talked about
today is in outcome three greater
efficiency resilience and sustainable
use of mineral and organic fertilizer
inputs but this is done in the uh
enabling environment of impr improved
policies Investments finances and
markets to ensure that access to the
right Technologies is enabled and then
also improved access and affordability
of the organic and mineral fertilizers
which overcomes one big barrier of
access and affordability and then also
we need to also pay attention to the
institutional and human capacity uh
development uh needs to be able to drive
the Innovation and promote the scaling
and um the um ad adoption of the uh
blood nutrition strategies that are site
specific crop specific but also fitting
the social economic context of small
orderer farmers I wanted to end this uh
highlight of the Continental agenda and
um we'll be pleased to further discuss
uh some of the key specific Technologies
um as we will have time for discussion
later thank you very much thank you very
much Shi for your very interesting
presentations and I congratulate you for
putting this together in view of time
you know I will move on to the next
presenter Mr tomoko harigaya Chief
scientist Precision
development uh who will talk about
digital agricultural Innovations to
Foster climate resilient small H system
over to you
tomoko thank
you it's great to be here um and you
know I very much appreciate the
opportunity to share our learnings with
all of you today um so as you know the
spread of mobile phones and you know new
technology and data present huge
opportunity to disseminate and deliver
customized information to small holder
farmers in real time in a way that's
really
unprecedented um and today you know I
like to bring in implementers
perspective to the discussion and and
share you know how we have approached to
take advantage of these Technologies uh
visal you know digital tools um and
share some of our experience um in India
next slide
please um so I'll start with a quick
introduction of precision development op
pxd for those of you who aren't familiar
with our work we are a nonprofit working
with government and other partners to
expand access to Innovations and
informations that millions of farmers
can use to improve their livelihoods and
digital agricultur advisory has been a
core part of our work um so we work
flexibly with different partners
depending on the needs in each context
so sometimes we take on the implemental
role um designing and delivering
customized information directly to
smolder Farmers but we also work with
Partners to make data driven
improvements to already existing digal
services or in some other settings we
take on the advisory role for the
government you know trying to integrate
digital Technologies into agriculture
extension next slide please
and over the years you know we've really
focused on building customized
Information Services for small water
Farmers that are sustainable at a very
large scale um and our general approach
is to combine farmer specific
information and available agricultural
data in a given context um and then we
create localized and dynamic information
that enables Farmers to optimize their
agricultural decisions um for instance
you know you might have a farmal
location profile
um and and so forth from Farmers that
you're working with and then you might
have agriculture data you know in a
specific context some some sometimes you
know so so Health Data there might be
meta forecasts market prices and so
forth um you know usually you don't have
all of this data in place at the start
and this is something that you build out
as you interact more with farmers and
learn about the context available
data uh next slide
please and then
one important element of of our work is
really to kind of create this feedback
loop that allows the service to iterate
and improve over time and there are a
few key elements to this uh first one is
that we use behavior science and the
human Center design approach to ensure
that farmers we targeting find The
Advisory messages relevant and
actionable um especially with
agricultural device or even things like
weather forecasts messages can get quite
Technical and hard to understand
especially in short messages so this is
something we pay a lot of attention
to second we use experiments and other
methods of data analysis to continuously
tested design tweaks to increase
engagement adoption and then third we
set up every service with scaling
partners of governments so that we can
rapidly reach you know hundreds of
thousands of farmers and keep the
service free free to them and there's a
sustainable path um and the scale of
course you know also means that you gain
kind of more data access and that allows
you to learn faster and increase impact
faster as
well all right next slide
please so now like how does all of this
look like in action I'll take one
example today uh from India work again
so pxd is Flagship program which is
called a microchip so this is a two
two-way voice platform where Farmers
receive customized agricultural device
on their mobile phones as recorded
messages and then they can also call in
and record a question to get an answer
from a government agronomist within you
know 48 hours or you know two to three
days um and in addition to agronomic
advice you Farmers also receive realtime
alerts uh on extreme weather event or
you know local past conditions where the
information was available
the service was co-designed with the
government of oresa and co-funded by the
government and the Gates Foundation but
the vision for sustainable model was
very clear from the start among all
stakeholders that pxd would you know
first build and improve the service um
and then you know that's again about
Gathering farmer feedback tweaking
messages or creating a dashboard and
other tools to help the government monor
usage over time right and then uh we
transition the to the government fully
after 5 years uh but this was all
planned so when we handed over the
service with nearly three million
Farmers on the platform in 2022 we also
handed over an operational team that was
already familiar with the the flow and
managing the service for a while and
really I think the remarkable thing was
you know the government was because
about that planning and and kind of
steps in place they were ready to take
it and B with it after you know the
transition they continue to expand the
service and now it's reaching over six
million Farmers covering think over 20
value chains
now next slide please and then in the
process of this scaling of the service
we also Incorporated a randomized
evaluation to measure the impact of the
service among rice Farmers today I'm
just touching on a few preliminary
findings and insights um so first
looking at the usage we saw a fairly
high and consistent engagement over two
years and then second we see a
significant increase in total RTE
production in particular a large impact
appears to be concentrated among farmers
in areas hit by certain types of weather
shocks so for example in the first year
of the evaluation there was this
concentrated heavy rainfall that
submerged plants in the middle of the
season the analysis seems to suggest
that access to amak crushi substantially
increased total production among those
farmers and then very excitingly we also
see a large reduction in the reported
likelihood of CIA crop loss due to
weather related events and this figure
you know comes from actually the second
year where the the the big shock was
actually the scarcity of rainfall so you
know this this part of the the geography
they get both too much rain and too
little rain and we seem to to see that
the you know generally the evaluation s
suggest that ad visory was helpful in
Pharm coping with these different types
of weather
shocks um three Insight that you know I
just want to quickly highlight first is
that these results seem to suggest that
there's there is a very large amount
need for climate information for for
small farmers to to cope with these
weather related events second we know
that different farmers face different
shocks and constraints across seasons
and who benefit from the service and by
how much will likely change from season
to season so we might see a large impact
in only a small subset of farmers in a
particular year but that doesn't mean
that the sh advisory won't be helpful
for other farmers in a different year so
so I think that kind of changes the way
we think about maybe impact measurement
and and and so forth and then lastly I
think to enable Farmers to improve their
climate resilience we see a big
opportunity again with all this new tech
Technologies and data to improve our
capabilities to identify the most
relevant localized climate risks um in
real
time next slide
please now I'll wrap wrap up with just a
few thoughts on the replicability of
these types of digital agricultural
advisory services so first um you know
one challenge we faced is the difficulty
of aligning donors and the government
interest at the same time so for
instance you know the government might
Express
enthusiasm um but it takes time to kind
of identify finding opportunity um and
and so forth so by then there may be
changes in the government or the
government may be busy with something
else to kind of collaborate on a a
proposal in a month um and and that you
know I I think that we really find
ourselves to to kind of find this big
opportunities lost because of these
challenges of aligning you know all the
the stakeholders at the same
time second once you do have an
opportunity to set up a digital
agricultural advisory service with the
government it's really important to
integrate the service into the existing
government
infrastructure um you know this can
enhance collaboration Buy in and
knowledge transfer which is absolutely
necessary to make the service
sustainable and then third systems Data
Systems data processes that can create a
feedback Lo a critical to maintaining
the impact at scale as we scale and
expand our Target farmer base we have to
ensure that the content continues to be
relevant for more diverse farmer needs
and environments and this requires
constant you know Farm feedback and
interations and I think one way that we
think about it is you know when we are
setting up these feedback mechanisms we
are reducing communication FRS between
farmers and governments and scientists
and in all the stat stakeholders and I
think that's a really important piece um
and then finally I think part of this
creating an effective feedback system is
about establishing a culture of
experimentation and learning um I think
the return to institutionalizing this
type of feedback mechanisms and a
culture of experimentation can generate
very large sustainable impact of course
we haven't really figured out how to do
all of this uh and we are constantly
learning and I'd love to hear from other
panelists and the audience about you
know their experience in scaling
Innovations and services this smalla
farmers thank
you thank you very much uh makiko for
your interesting presentation on you
know how digital Innovation you know can
play its role in in in our discussion
very interesting and uh I I I
congratulate you for this presentation
and for keeping it within the time now I
would like to move on to to our next
presenter who will be talking about
promoting enterpreneurship and Agri food
Innovations in the Dryland is my honor
to invite uh Mr tamy
adoro managing partner shahel Consulting
Agriculture and nutrition Tammy over to
[Music]
you thank you very much uh can you can
you see my screen and hear me yes okay
good uh good afternoon from Koo Nigeria
um good evening good morning to you all
um where you are um has introduced I
head sah Consulting a consulting firm
focused on transforming the food and
agriculture landscape across Africa and
I'll be speaking uh on promoting
entrepreneurship and Agri food
Innovations in drylands focusing on
Africa uh just to quickly um you know
mentioned that I mean it's a reminder
that Africa is not really endowed for
agult excellence and uh we know why um
about 50 to 70% of the population is
involved in agriculture uh 80% of the
food produced been produced by by
Farmers small scale producers and we
have about 60% of the world arable land
um but of course we know uh some of the
issues we're facing with Dryland
Agriculture and you know uh the
significance of Dryland agriculture on
how to make to ensure that uh we make
drand agriculture uh more resilient more
more
sustainable um I want to speak today
highlighting three uh ways to three
critical ways uh to promote
entrepreneurship and agre food
Innovations uh in drylands the first
would be focused on uh empowering smmes
uh in agriculture to build resilience
against shocks of climate uh the second
will be scaling up private sector
engagements with with more the farmers
and they thought will be promoting
Market Le
initiatives um we uh we are currently uh
implementing a program uh called the
building resilience against climate
climate and environmental shocks uh
brace uh which basically is focused on
uh intensive capacity development um to
support AF African agult smmes uh to
become aware of how the businesses are
affected by climate change and you know
enabling them to develop strategies to
Mi mitigate them it's quite it's quite
um um a very intensive program over
1,200 smmes across 30 countries in
Africa have been trained and we're
beginning to see increased uh business
efficiency of these agre businesses at
least about 30% of them are beginning to
adopt clim smart agricultural
practices um on the next slide I wanted
to highlight um if some some of the um
some of some some part of the data
Diagnostics uh coming out of the
training and really to say uh you can
see how the knowledge of country level
uh climate smart agriculture uh policies
uh have
increased to almost over 90% just uh
from from the training
activities as well as the knowledge of
of climate smart ult approaches many of
the participants actually didn't even
know or were not aware of any uh climate
smart agricultural practices pre predd
trining and it's quite encouraging to
see that and uh I can I can you know say
that many of these train hagri smes are
beginning to adopt uh various practices
uh in their businesses uh in the
drylands and just to before moving on on
this slide to highlight that I think
addressing climate shocks in drylands uh
to start with increasing the knowledge
of the key value chain actors very
important uh businesses or or small
scale
producers um moving on the second I want
to highlight here really is scaling
private sector engagement with with
small farmers and I think if we're going
to promote
entrepreneurship um you know promote
Agri food Innovations in in drylands we
need to encourage many of the private
sector partners that are playing in that
space um and there are quite a number of
uh unique innovative business models
that many private organizations have
explored
um explored you know ranging from uh
informal engagement between
entrepreneurs and smaller Farmers or
intermediary uh where they sign foral
you know contracts where we have former
subcontracting of companies and and and
aggregators farmer groups um you know to
engage Farmers to to to to directly you
know upake their produce all you know
more centralized models or nucleus
estate model where these companies are
you know setting up farms and engaging
Farmers there but the unique thing about
these private sector engagement uh
models is that uh many of the critical
services that small scale producers
require in Dryland uh come with these
service provision models uh you know
providing sustainable ecosystem for the
farmers uh providing access to input
Services training uh ensuring effective
system providing mechanization support
storage support and uh the the most
important of all is know the fact that
there is Market access and these models
are are becoming more and more prominent
on the continent especially in in
drylands across sever Valley chains and
I think one of the ways to encourage um
you know Agri businesses um working in
this in this space is to really support
the scaling efforts uh in ensuring that
many more value chains are reached and
many more small scale producers are
reached as well and of course more food
is produced this U is something that I
think is very
important um the third uh initiative
that I would highlight or way that I
think we need that we we can explore to
uh promote entrepreneurship and hry food
Innovation is by promoting Market Le
initiatives and there are several of
them but I I want to highlight
one called the advancing local Dair
development in Nigeria program that is
currently being led by sah Consulting uh
robust uh comp comp complex program uh
leveraging ecosystem uh model or methods
to address the issues within the da U
sector in Nigeria but not just
addressing issues within the da sector
ensuring that uh we are uh you know
creating or building more entrepreneur
capacity within rural communities um in
both Dairy and nir
communities uh so far the housing
program has uh been able to form about
form Farmers into about
2,600 67 s up groups uh you know formed
into over 200 cooperatives now we have
more than 11,000 women that are trained
on different entrepreneur
entrepreneurship uh you know business
models ranging from know poetry go
raring vegetable
cultivation uh soap making petroleum
jelly and you can see some of the
numbers there how these women have been
able to and through collaboration with
uh private sector uh Dairy processors
have been able to sell me qu over 2
million USD uh in the last uh three and
a half years and uh within the program
we've been able to also train more than
200 Community Based entrepreneurs uh who
are providing various you degree of
services um as artificial technicians V
Community Based Animal hband Service Pro
service providers these I think um you
know has created a unique uh business
part business pathway within communities
and you know helping Farmers to to uh
really you know increase income uh just
to highlight uh what that is looking
like in terms of income diversification
for women we can see uh some two women
groups here that I highlight
um in both can and Adama Nigeria with
income diversification training they
beginning to really uh explore uh you
know poltry businesses and we're
beginning to see that these businesses
are becoming sustainable because uh it's
they've not just done it one off they
continue to reinvest um you know their
profit and plow plow back into uh
actually doing more uh this for us
believe a success story that um if we
support these kind of initiatives uh we
definitely can do more in dry lands the
the other one is uh around uh nutrition
uh education vegetable gardening and how
uh training women uh and Men on the
principles of diet diversity and
supporting them to actually create
Gardens have led to not just ensuring
that they have food for their household
but they also have uh vegetables to sell
and they're making uh money at the
community level it also just shows that
uh if we scale several Market Le
initiatives like this one uh we have uh
likely going to be able to achieve a lot
more uh in you know encouraging
entrepreneurship in in drylands and and
ensuring food uh
availability um it's this is my last
slide I I just want to end by uh
specifically highlighting some very
practical steps that I think we need to
consider in addition to those three
initiatives I think we need to support
Agri food entrepreneurs to scale
successful private sector Le initiatives
I talk about some backward integration
models uh between private sector and and
and and Farmers uh service provision
models as well um we need to leverage
infrastructure to annest the Dryland
some of the most important Dryland
resources and I think I mean solar
energy comes to mind uh uh I mean we can
aness the power of solar energy in
drylands to power Agriculture and power
other sectors in Africa and I think that
would definitely bring a lot more
development to the into the drylands and
I think we need to support the creation
of um a Pan African policy platform for
uh a coordinated voice on on how to
develop drylands I think that's has
become uh critical now more than ever
before uh we need to empower
entrepreneurs to build resilience
against climate shocks um with the
little we can achieve on brace I believe
that with more uh education around
climate and support I believe that many
entrepreneurs would emerge from within
the drylands and of course the the final
the final one would be the creation of a
knowledge sharing Hub I think data is
extremely important and knowledge
exchange information exchange is very
critical for business decision making
and uh you know evidence program design
and implementation um I I will stop
there and um I'll wait for the question
and answer session thank you so much
thank you very much uh tamy for sharing
your uh experience on this and nice to
see how this interpr entrepreneurship
aspect entrepreneurship aspect in in in
your work and in in in sub Sahara Africa
in view of time uh I will move on to our
final
presenters um I would like to invite
Marcela lus de ro uh who is uh from fa
El Salvador she will be talking about
climate building climate resilient
landscape through local knowledge and
innovation in Central America's dry
Corridor Marcela over to
you thank you very much JY and hello to
all the audience that is joining us
today h from all over the world my name
is Marcel lemus and I am a specialist in
resilient agriculture for the green
climate fund project reima in F El
Salvador and I'm very grateful H to
share on behalf of the reima team our
experience in building climate resilient
Landscapes through sustainable
agriculture measures so to start with
our presentation I will talk a little
bit about the dry Corridor in Central
America which it covers 44% of Guatemala
Honduras El Salvador in nicwa and as you
can see we are located in El Salvador
and the country is within the the region
however the reima project is on
108 districts H which were selected
through ER those territories having high
and severe drought and communities
within the dry Corridor are severely
affected by climate change events ER
mainly for long periods of drought
followed by intense rains and also land
degradation
and we have talked also a another
panelists have talked also about water
scarcity in the region affecting crops
animal production and human consumption
unfortunately we still have un
sustainable management practices in
agricultural production which leads to
an inadequate management of Natural
Resources especially Soil and
Water so under this context we have the
upscaling climate resilient measures in
the dry corridor agroecosystems of El
Salvador better known as reima project
which was formulated in 2018 and it is
financed by the green climate fund and
the Salvadoran the Salvadorian
government and FES for a total of
$27.6 million the project aims to H
increase the resilience of the
livelihoods of the population living in
the dry Corridor to climate change and
this is align with the objective of the
Global program on sustainable Dryland
agriculture which aims to empower small
scale producers by building
technical ER capacities to protect
natural resources under a changing
climate H the project has three main
outputs the first one aims to improve
the resilience of the livelihoods and
production systems in Family Farms the
second one h is more related with the
restoration processes of critical areas
such as water recharge zones riparian
zones buffer zones of natural protected
areas in order to increase the
resilience of flows of environmental
services at landscape levels and finally
we have output number three which aims
to improve the governance and
information flow in support of
sustainability and scaling up basically
this output is is the foundation of the
sustainability of outputs one and two
but for today's presentation we will
focus on output number one where we are
applying an Innovative approach in terms
of capacity building and Agricultural
Extension methodology we are working
with Farmers field schools but using a
figure of a community promoter who is a
leader farmer within their communities
and they are selected under certain
criteria we have technical staff
facilitating these farmer field schools
with these Community promoters after
that H Community promoters replicate the
knowledge with a group of farmers within
their communities in average each
Community promoters have um 35 farmers
and that's why as you can see by 2024 we
have achieved more than 40
6,000 Farmers already because I think
that we all or mainly in in in the old
countries we have a lack of Human
Resources however we are creating
capacities of these people H not just to
building capacities but also to provide
technical assistance within the farmers
we have the participation of women Youth
and Indigenous people and we have
achieved already more than 41 ,000
hectares where farmers are applying at
least two sustainable
practices so which are the key
implemented strategies that we are
implementing to transform Dryland
agriculture where first of all we have
the traditional knowledge we have a
validation of the sustainable practices
with indigenous peoples and other key
actors H and actually indigenous peoples
were very happy that we were rescuing
some of these practices as we will see
they are not new and people stop doing
them obviously for you the use of
products or other technology that is not
that are not environmentally friendly
and but facilitates the work for them
another important strategy is the
governance and institutional
strengthening and here we are working
with uh local committees that are
integrated by loal governments ngos a
community based organization among
another key actors and this is actually
one of the things that have motivated
producers to implement the practices as
well because for example in some
territories we have local governments
supporting uh producers with additional
inputs or technical assistance and at
the same time local governments can
comply with Environmental regulations
within their territories for example
with uh the not burning in the
agricultural
areas another important thing is
technology and the use of digital tools
Community promoters have compiled
Baseline information of producers on the
ground using Cobo collect tool and they
also have been following up the
implementation of the practices of their
group of farmers use
this H tool as I said the capacity
building through the farmer field
schools it's an Innovative approach
within the project and we are leaving a
human capital in the territories not
only for this initiative but for some of
the future initiatives um in the country
and even when capacity building is very
important we cannot forget about
technical assistance and this has been
also a key factor of success for the
implementation of the practices because
Farmers ER can have access to these
service and they also are more motivated
for the implementation of the
sustainable
measures so which are the sustainable
agricultural practices as I may as I
mentioned these are not new and we are
working with no burning no tillage h
stab management contourline planting
live barriers infiltration ditches
infiltration pits H death barriers the
establishment of f bank with varieties
tolerant to droughts and floods and the
production of organic fertilizers the
establishment of Agro forestry and Silo
pasture systems the use of local
varieties that are resistant resilient
to the conditions of the dry Corridor
and the implementation of drip
irrigation
systems in some areas where water is
available and even when we are not
working with the concept of keson wild
systems all the activities we are
promoting among the farmers ER include
this important H element of a
traditional knowledge H including also
an integrated man management integr P
management and the use of or of the
biomass as a result of the pr of the
trees ER to fertilize and and improve
the
soil and all these practices also we are
using the exact tool H for the
estimation of carbon sequestration and
we already have a 590,000 tons of carbon
dioxide equ equivalent capture H at this
time at this stage of the project that H
is the 70% of the goal we have and this
is directly linked to the soil
conservations soil futility and moisture
retention that um impacts and improve
the productivity and livelihoods of uh
our people and I think that this is very
key because ER some of our producers
obviously they they are aware about the
about taking care of the resources but
they also are ER experiencing by
themselves the benefits of implementing
these practices in the cost reductions
and the Improvement of
yields so to sum up I just want to
mention that it is very important as
other panelists have mentioned as well
to H focus on an integrated approach
it is very important to rescue the local
knowledge including Innovative
Technologies processes capacity building
h technical assistance in order to reach
a a better and and sustainable dryland
farming thank you very
much thank you very much Marcela for
sharing fao's experience let's let's say
you know how f is in action in this dry
Corridor uh I think it's very
interesting and I also link it back to
what makiko Beth and uh uh jaie said you
know action at scale I think through
green climate fund although you know
there is a sizable amount of funding uh
but to increase it skill it really you
know require government commitment and
and other stakeholder commitment to
support the dry Corridor program in the
region where you are working so thank
you very much for that and
Marcela colleagues now we have time a
bit of time not much for answering
questions that are not yet uh very you
know answers that have been
Q&A um in in in the chat and uh I can
see that some of the uh uh panels me you
know have have start answering these uh
questions but not all of them but let me
have a quick look on these um perhaps I
can go to first to uh
makiko um there is a question I think
from uh Mr Alex
Narco uh who is the FAO represent
representative in
Djibouti um he is asking about you know
where to get the cuttings of cactus
because jouti is also dry uh if you can
attempt to that question quickly makiko
over to you thank you very much Yi I I
think I just as answered that question
in the chat too but just quickly
answering that um Cactus does exist
already in the country so first and
foremost way is to best make use of the
the species that are available Thea
species but uh the cactus net can also
uh facilitate uh different uh uh
genetic resources to be shared from uh G
Banks and other um entities uh through
appropriate means uh so please contact
me for
further information thank you thank you
makiko and Alex this is an internal
discussion that you will not you will
need to follow up with makiko now we
have this question from Sergio Torres
what is the percentage of small holders
that could have access to digital
agriculture or given data that is
understandable to all uh and not
dependent on the international or
government cooperation perhaps tomoko
you can shed some light on this if you
have uh you know any
idea um I that's that's a you know very
difficult question I think you know one
is that like I think there are a lot of
different you know stakeholders ERS and
different digital an programs and you
know they're working with it at
different
scales um you know in theory I think
there
are like I think there are different
ways of reaching Farmers one is directly
trying to reach Farmers through their
mobile phones but I think there are a
lot of programs that are also just
leveraging you know availability of
mobile mobile phones in the community so
you can go through extension workers if
you you know provide more real time
information through extension workers
you may be able to reach farmers who
don't actually have a mobile phone
access or or in remote areas um you know
perhaps Agro dealers and there are other
kind of leader farmers and other points
of contact within communities that that
you can Target in order to increase
access to
information indirectly as well um so I
don't have a specific percent number
that I can you know I can share but I
think
that the probably the the proportion is
very very high at this
point okay is there any uh uh panel
members who want to add to that I think
it also depends on the context you know
and and condition in different countries
right any any of you want to add to
that I don't see any uh hand from the
panels um I also
uh see quite a few of other
question um for example you know Derek
makiko please how can we find
you okay very interesting question so I
leave it to you later makiko to explain
to Derek uh where you are hiding in
Rome okay
um I see
that okay uh Alejandro JZ the problem of
Dryland is is that they are dry climate
change will intensify this condition
particularly in hot countries can you
expand uh fo suggested strategy to
overcome this huge challenge for
instance in Middle East or meso America
uh some comments on water energy Nexus
in rural zones I think this is not only
for FAO I think is also open to all
panelists right so perhaps uh I use my
power to perhap ask Jackie uh what is
your perspective on this Jackie um how
to you know to overcome this huge
Challenge and especially taking into
account water energy Nexus in the rural
[Music]
Zone thank you I was just thinking about
water dry lands because there is
water there is you can condense water in
the desert in the mornings you can find
groundw but what's happening is that
when you get sudden rains like we're
getting with climate change it runs off
and we're not it's not going into the
water table and so yes technically
you're losing it and I think
that again this is a huge Regional
approach because you can't
fix the dry lands by fixing one corner
of
it um Greening across the
SEL with trees and other vegetation
that's a good start because if we can
get it green it will retain water so
decent crops that are not wasting water
are not a bad way to start as
well can I pass it to someone else now
Yodi yeah thank you jaie that is helpful
um any other panel members want to
contribute to
that if not then uh I have a question
also digital Agriculture and new
business models have a lot of potential
to promote more resilient Dryland
systems um what are key bottlenecks to
developing and scaling up successful
model perhaps I I would like to ask tamy
or tomoko to respond to that maybe start
with
tamy no thanks thanks very much Yodi I I
would say maybe two things um the the
first um bottleneck uh would be uh that
you know many many of those business
models are implemented by small and
medium scale businesses um on the
continent many of those businesses
struggle a lot uh struggle for to access
information struggle to you know
understand the political Dynamics and
how it affect the businesses you know
struggle to access the right resources
right so I I I think one of the things
we need to do is to uh encourage um you
know the the creation of you know
communities that encourage these
businesses to be able to come together
work together and really support each
other learn from each other and maybe
that's just what they need to to be able
to scale their you know um unique
innovative business models and and I've
seen that in practice with the work uh
we're doing I'm also the executive chair
at African food Change makers which is
uh a you know uh a hub a community of
entrepreneurs across the continent and
I'm beginning to
see um a lot of uh impacts on businesses
that are within the Hub uh currently uh
Hub house members are across more than
43 countries in Africa and you know it
keeps growing every day and it shows
that it's just one of those critical
things that that is needed the other
second uh point would be um every
innovative business model no matter how
Innovative it is also require Innovative
financing and I think and I think we
need to rethink you know the concept of
financing for you know uh agricultural
Innovations of business Innovations in
Africa and ensure that uh those
businesses have access to the right you
know financing that is not expensive and
that is you know
competitive thank you tamy uh tomoko any
addition from you briefly maybe just
quickly kind of adding to Timmy's last
point about financing model I think um
one thing you know that that's difficult
is you know when you're building a
service for like a small scale p OT you
know time bound pilot the things that
you need to figure out to be successful
there may not be the same as things
questions that you need to figure out to
create a you know long-term sustainable
model at scale you know it's about
technology needs the data security
Quality Maintenance and of course
importantly resourcing as well um so I
think I think there a kind of bringing
in how you know the vision of how the
the service would really look like and
what you need to figure out um from the
beginning I think is something really
important but but challenging because of
the way lot of the funding is
structured yeah thank you very much now
uh last question and I hope the answer
will be brief I would like to direct it
to shami and
Marcela uh for you to you know to answer
what are some of the key Technologies
and Innovation that you think have
potential to truly impact Dryland
ecosystems and Market systems in the
coming years uh Marcela you may want to
reflect you know from your you know GCF
experience and and shami from your own
experience in Africa maybe shami you can
start
first yes thank you very much um yeah I
just want to speak from the context of
addressing the key pertinent challenges
from a technological perspective uh
water carbon and nutrients and we need
Integrated Solutions that help to
conserve water and then ensure that we
are adding sufficient and balanced
nutrients and then as well as carbon so
there's a whole uh range of technologies
that need to be fit into specific
context and um conservation agriculture
is one technology that um has great
potential because it addresses all the
three um you know essential components
but we have to pay more attention to
water harvesting water conservation and
then combine that with um nutrient
inputs from uh organic resources and
mineral fertilizers but more importantly
also invest in the right um crops and uh
plant species that are adapted to the
poor swells and low rentfor situations
as well and I want to highlight the role
of legumes in the systems where they can
add high quality biomass for improving
nitrogen Supply that can actually add
more nutrients through more sustainable
processes thank you very much thank you
shami Marcel
yes I think that um it is very important
to have technology in order to provide
uh what for forecast for
farmers in terms of uh decision making
in know Salvador for example the big
question every year is when should I
plant yes but still we also need for
example um technical recommendations
about how to prepare
during the dry season just to face any
event that can come within the rainy
season and sometimes farmer just and
they harvest their crops and they forget
about the plot H but in the meantime
they can still H Implement a sustainable
practices just to minimize the impacts
and so I think that that's very
important that's why I really ER was
interested in in what tomoko share about
the app they the already have we are
still working on how to provide this
information to FAS thank you thank you
very much Marcela very useful um
colleagues I know that there are many
questions you know because drylands are
so huge problems are so big
opportunities are so big you know
potential uh you know immens uh I don't
think we can solve all the question at
this webinar certainly from FAO part
what I can say is that we will continue
you know to use this platform uh you
know to advance the
discussion uh but because of time you
know I really would like uh to end the
webinar and it is my great honor to
invite uh my colleagues uh uh Mr Abdul
Hakim El the assistant director General
and Regional representative for uh North
uh Africa RNE who is here with us uh
thank you very much hakeim for your time
I know you are very busy and with that
you know we give the closing uh to you
over to you hakeim thank
you Yi uh thank you very much and thank
you to I see Beth beol here and all the
colleagues uh um I'm really really
grateful for for this opportunity what a
great pleasure that we have here today
it's indeed a very important webinar uh
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests uh as we come to the close of
this uh enlightening seminar on
resilient dry lands innovating for
sustainable agriculture Landscapes and
livelihoods I would like to express my
deepest thanks gratitude to all our
speakers for sharing their expertise and
all to all participants for your active
engagement throughout the day I think
this is a very important subject and and
I'm really grateful for everybody I
represent the near East and North Africa
region which is one of the driest region
we'll hear more about it it has been a
privilege to learn about the Innovative
approaches that are being implemented in
Dryland regions uh across the globe from
Africa uh to Central America to
everywhere else in the world each
contributing to the creation of more
resilient agriculture Landscapes and
livelihoods indeed dry land does not
mean
westand does not mean Wasteland so the
the urgency for ecosystem restoration is
very evident with uh nearly three
quarters of the regions
rainfed cropland degraded and water
scarcity projected to cause substantial
uh economic loss by
2050 in the near e North Africa region
alone one of the driest regions in the
world we Face similar challenges
including water scarcity drought
desertification land use rather land
misuse land use changes and degradation
all of which are exagerated by the
impact of climate change leading to
significant economic losses amounting to
about 9 billion dollar a year uh or up
to about 7% of the national gdps of Our
member countries these issues have
serious ramifications on the food
security livelihoods and overall
well-being of the populations mainly
living in dry lands yet these challenges
are not
insurable um the the inspiring solutions
that we've discussed and heard today
ranging from integrating traditional
knowledge with Cutting Edge Technologies
to enhancing soil health and promoting
Agri food
entrepreneurship prove that there are
clear Pathways and hopes and
opportunities to sustainable development
in Dryland areas one key
takeaways from this webinar is that
resilience in dry lands must be
multifaceted it cannot be
single Direction it is not just about
increasing productivity but also about
preserving ecosystems fostering
Innovation and building local capacities
to adapt to shocks and stresses most
importantly it is about empowering the
farmers and communities who are at the
heart of these very challenging
landscapes
sop pastoral strategies are particularly
relevant to Dryland areas with forests
woodlands and Mosaic of different land
uses and tener ecosystems trees in
Dryland forests and wooded areas provide
essential ecosystems services including
animal feed Timber fruits shap and
regulation of soil and water cycles
equally livestock production is
considered a key activity for food
security local knowledge enhanced by
research and Innovation can create
nature-based
solutions that improve food security
support livelihoods and restore Dryland
ecosystems all while safeguarding
ecosystem services and achieving land
deg ration neutrality I would like to
highlight here in particular the region
from the near East the importance of the
a Oasis regions most of the Oasis that
we have are in the middle of the dry
lands and the deserts and there are key
initiatives of creating alliances on
Oasis development that we'd like to
focus on as we go in the future as one
of the most fragile communities within
dry lands as we conclude the seminar I
urge each of you to take decisive
actions these are there are several key
action areas that I wish to highlight as
a result of today's discussion notably
as a development Community we must one
invest in research and Innovation let us
intensify our efforts to develop and
scale up Technologies tailored to dry
land conditions this includes not only
agricultural Innovations but also
digital solutions that can Empower
farmers and realtime information big
data analytics and improved Market
access two promote policy integration I
urge policy makers to ensure that
Dryland agriculture is mainstreamed into
NA national development strategies
climate action plans and food security
policies we need holistic approaches
that recognize the interconnectedness of
land water and biodiversity management
three Foster
Partnerships the complex challenges of
dry lands require collaborative
Solutions let us strengthen Partnerships
between governments rear research
institutions the private sector the
local
communities if stands ready to facil
these connections and provide technical
support and
guidance three um uh sorry four Empower
local communities we must ensure that
the custodians of Dryland ecosystems
Farmers pastoralist and Indigenous
people are at the heart of our
interventions their knowledge and active
participation are crucial for
sustainable outcomes
five scale up successful models many of
the solutions presented today are right
for scaling up I challenge all
stakeholders to identify successful
initiatives that can be adapted and
expanded in your respective regions
Sixth and last enhanc knowledge sharing
the insights gained from this seminar
webinar should not remain Within These
virtual walls
I encourage you to disseminate this
knowledge widely initiate follow-up
discussions and contribute to Global
platforms focused on Dryland agriculture
focusing more on local communities the
United Nations decade for on ecosystem
restoration which FAO is co leading with
unip provides an excellent platform and
an opportunity to disseminate the best
practices across regions ladies and
gentlemen and all participants to this
webinar as we look ahead to the 29th
session of the fo committee on
agriculture and the ongoing
implementation of the global program on
sustainable Dryland agriculture your
active engagement will be crucial I
would also like to acknowledge the
collaboration between the committee on
agriculture coag and the committee on
Forestry kof
on cross- sectoral matters and the
cooperation with members on scaleup
actions on Agriculture and Forestry
linkages in the near East and North
Africa region we have reflected this
collaboration on Dryland restoration
through our Regional Conference of the
Ministers of Agriculture within our near
eest
region the transformation of Dryland
Agri Food Systems is not just an
environmental necessity it is a pathway
to achieving multiple sustainable
development goals especially that we're
approaching our Target for 2030 and we
know that we are 75% off track of all
the
sdgs in closing I want to express my
heartful gratitude to all speakers
participants and organizers who have
made this seminar a success
it's indeed um a lesson and a school to
learn from for you know one single day
your dedication to this cause is truly
inspiring let us leave here today not
just with new knowledge but with a
renewed commitment for Action together
we can build a resilient drylands that
sustain both people and the planet for
generations to
I really thank you Yi and the whole
division for for for for organizing this
seminar bringing people from different
aspects and we at the near Eastern North
Africa region have learned a lot being
one of the driest regions in the world
of how do we sustain our ecosystems
especially in drylands so I'm really
really grateful for this opportunity and
look forward for uh continue to to learn
lessons from from such interactions
thank
you thank you very much hakeim for your
really really excellent summaries with
six accent point that you urge all of us
to come we promise we'll follow up the
team with me will will not just stop in
this let's say you know online webinar
we will go into action together
colleagues uh esteem panel members
participants you know I noticed at some
point we are more than 230 and now until
now we are still close to 140 allow me
on behalf of FAO also and to Second the
point of hakeim to thanks all of you for
making this webinar really a truly you
know a platform for sharing
inspirational and also educational as
Hakim said colleagues with that thank
you so much I wish you nice evening nice
day and uh stay tune we will come back
with more uh high quality webinar like
this one thank you so much colleagues
and bye-bye